>>> FAMILIES OF 9/11 VICTIMS ARE
URGING FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
CANCEL A SAUDI-BACKED GOLF
TOURNAMENT THAT IS SET TO BE
HELD AT THIS GOLF COURSE JUST
OUTSIDE OF NEW YORK CITY IN
BEDMINSTER, NEW JERSEY.
MEMBERS OF THE 9/11 GROUP ARE
REQUESTING A MEETING TO TRUMP
WRITING TO HIM IN A LETTER,
QUOTE, WE SIMPLY CANNOT
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU CAN AGREE TO
ACCEPT MONEY IN THE KINGDOM OF
SAUDI ARABIA'S GOLF LEAGUE TO
ACCEPT THEIR GOLF TOURNAMENT AND
TO DO SO IN THE SHADOWS OF
GROUND ZERO IN NEW JERSEY WHICH
LOST OVER 700 RESIDENTS.
JOINING US, JULIETTE, HER FATHER
WAS ONE OF HUNDREDS OF
FIREFIGHTERS KILLED IN 9/11.
JULIET, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
I KNOW YOU WERE 4 YEARS OLD WHEN
YOUR DAD WAS KILLED.
TELL US WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT
TO YOU NOT ONLY TO NOT HOLD THE
TOURNAMENT BUT SO CLOSE TO
GROUND ZERO.
>> I MEAN, MYSELF AND I CAN
SPEAK FOR THE OTHER FAMILIES ARE
ABSOLUTELY ASTOUNDED.
WHEN WE FIRST FOUND OUT ABOUT
THE LIV TOURNAMENT IN GENERAL,
AND HOW IT WAS GOING TO BE
TAKING PLACE ON AMERICAN SOIL AT
ALL, THE FIRST BEING IN OREGON,
IT WAS JUST SHOCK,
DISAPPOINTMENT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
REALLY HURTFUL, BUT NOW FOR IT
TO BE TAKING PLACE, YOU KNOW,
LITERALLY, IN THE BACKYARD OF
GROUND ZERO, IN A STATE WHERE
THERE ARE A LOT OF 9/11 VICTIMS
IN NEW JERSEY, NEW YORK.
AND IT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY -- IT'S
SHOCKING.
AND FOR THAT TO BE HOSTED BY A
FORMER PRESIDENT IS EVEN MORE,
YOU KNOW, DISGUSTING.
IT'S JUST, YOU KNOW, IT'S HARD
TO FIND THE WORDS.
>> AND NOT JUST A FORMER
PRESIDENT, THIS IS A FORMER
PRESIDENT WHO ALSO BLAMED SAUDI
ARABIA FOR THE ATTACK SEVERAL
YEARS AGO, BEFORE HE TOOK
OFFICE.
HE DID BLAME THEM.
OF COURSE, YOU SAW THE
RELATIONSHIP HE HAD WITH THEM
WHEN HE WAS IN OFFICE.
YOU'VE WRITTEN THIS LETTER.
HAVE YOU GOTTEN ANY KIND OF
RESPONSE THUS FAR?
>> NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF.
AND, YES, TRUMP HIMSELF SAID IN
2016 THAT THE SAUDIS WERE
RESPONSIBLE.
AS FOR THE EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM
PRESIDENT BIDE THAN WE NOW HAVE
THESE DOCUMENTS, WE HAVE THESE
FBI DOCUMENTS THAT SHOW, YOU
KNOW, IT SHOWS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT THE SAUDIS
HAD, THEIR ROLE IN IT, SO, WE
NOW HAVE THE PROOF, YOU KNOW,
TRUMP WAS RIGHT.
BUT NOW HE'S TAKING MONEY FROM
THEM AND PROFITING FROM THE
KINGDOM OF SAUDI ARABIA.
MEANWHILE, THE KINGDOM IS
CURRENTLY AWAITING TRIAL, IN
FEDERAL COURT.
AGAINST THE 9/11 FAMILIES OVER
THESE ATTACKS.
YOU KNOW, OF COURSE, WE ARE
AWAITING THAT JUSTICE.
BUT YEAH, IT'S HARD TO FIND THE
WORDS.
>> I KNOW YOU'VE WRITTEN THIS
LETTER.
YOUR GROUP HAS WRITTEN THIS
LETTER TO HIM VOICING THIS.
BUT IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO HIM
DIRECTLY WHAT WOULD YOU SAY?
ABOUT WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT.
IT'S NOT A POLITICAL ISSUE, IT'S
PERSONAL FOR YOU.
>> IT IS PERSONAL.
AND I THINK FOR PEOPLE THAT
DON'T HAVE PERSONAL LOSS TO 9/11
OR NOT CLOSE TO IT, OR HAVE A
STORY OR SPECIFIC CONNECTION TO
THAT DAY.
YOU KNOW, IT'S REALLY EASY,
EVERY YEAR AROUND THE
ANNIVERSARY.
EVERYONE HEARS THE NAMES BEING
READ.
THEY HEAR ABOUT IS 9/11.
THEY ALL POST "NEVER FORGET."
IT'S REALLY EASY IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A PERSONAL CONNECTION TO
THE WAYS.
BEHIND EVERY NAME THEY HAD A
LIFE, A FAMILY, HOW THEY
PREFERRED THEIR COFFEE IN THE
MORNING.
YOU HEAR THEIR NAME, BUT THERE
IS A FAMILY STILL LIVING WITH A
MASSIVE HOLE IN THEIR LIVES.
YOU KNOW, IT DOESN'T GET ANY
EASIER.
IF ANYTHING, IT GETS HARDER, I'M
ADULT NOW AND I CAN PROCESS WHAT
ALL OF THAT MEANT.
AND NOW I'M VERY MUCH INVOLVED
IN FIGHTING FOR THE JUSTICE FOR
MY FATHER THAT HE SO RIGHTLY
DESERVED.
I MEAN, HE WAS A FIREMAN.
AND HE SACRIFICED HIS LIFE.
MY WORRMOTHER WAS A WIDOW AT 39.
AND SHE HAD TO RAISE FOUR
CHILDREN BY HERSELF.
AND WE WERE ROBBED OF, YOU KNOW,
A NORMAL CHILDHOOD OF THE LIVES
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE HAD WITH MY
FATHER.
AND IT'S BEEN OVER 20 YEARS.
IT'S REALLY TIME FOR JUSTICE.
>> YEAH.
AND THAT DOESN'T GO AWAY.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT, THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED THAT
SHAPED YOUR LIFE FOREVER.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT YOU ARE BEING SO
VOCAL ABOUT THIS AND TALKING
ABOUT IT.
AND MAKING YOUR FEELINGS KNOWN
ON IT.
WHAT KIND OF MESSAGE DOES IT
SEND IF TRUMP DOESN'T CANCEL
THIS?
IT'S NOT JUST THIS ONE.
HE'S ALSO GOT ANOTHER ONE AT HIS
GOLF COURSE IN MIAMI TOWARDS THE
END OF THE SEASON.
SO, IT'S NOT JUST ONE.
I UNDERSTAND IT'S PERSONAL,
BECAUSE THIS IS SO MUCH CLOSER,
BUT WHAT KIND OF MESSAGE DOES IT
SEND TO THE GLOBAL COMMUNITY, IF
HE DOESN'T CANCEL IT?
>> I MEAN, I THINK THE 9/11
COMMUNITY, WE'VE BEEN PRETTY
OUTSPOKEN ABOUT OUR ISSUE HERE.
AND I'M VERY PROUD TO SAY THAT I
THINK WE'VE GOTTEN OUR MESSAGE
OUT QUITE FAR.
AND, YOU KNOW, OUR MESSAGE IS ON
THE RADAR, YOU KNOW.
HE, I'M SURE, MR. TRUMP KNOWS
ABOUT US.
HE KNOWS THE LETTER.
HE KNOWS HOW WE STAND.
NOW WHETHER IT'S CANCELLED OR
NOT, I PERSONALLY DON'T THINK IT
WILL BE.
BUT JUST THE FACT THAT YOU'RE --
YOU ARE -- AND EVEN THE PLAYERS,
THIS IS BLOOD MONEY THAT YOU'RE
TAKING.
SAME WITH HIM HOSTING THESE
EVENTS.
ED FACT THAT THE KINGDOM OF
SAUDI ARABIA, WHEN WE HAVE
DECLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS  S TTHATE
THEIR INVOLVEMENT IN THIS.
AND THAT THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
OPERATE ON AMERICAN SOIL WITH
COMPLETE IMPUNITY IS ABSOLUTELY
SHOCKING.
AND, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE TRYING TO
SPORTS WASH THEIR WAY THROUGH
THIS.
THEY HAVE A VERY LONG HISTORY OF
HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS.
NOT JUST 9/11.
AND THEIR WAY OF TRYING TO ERASE
IS THROUGH SPORTS.
I MEAN, WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
FIGHT THAT AS MUCH AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN.
BECAUSE IT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT
RIGHT.
>> IT'S AN HONORABLE EFFORT.
I KNOW THIS ISN'T EASY TO COME
ON.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON AND IT'S
AN IMPORTANT MESSAGE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.